Program complete.
You may enter when ready.
This video series primarily focuses on film and television,
but every once in a while I like to check in on the world of video games and
there's no better place to get a sense of what's happening in gaming than the
electronic entertainment expo or e three for short.
Every summer,
the entire video game industry descends on the Convention Center in downtown Los
Angeles for an extravagant week of video game announcements and demonstrations.
The highlight of the expo or the press conferences,
which are put on by each of the major video game publishers during which they
showcase all their latest and greatest title.
Yes,
dozens of fantastically rendered breathtaking world's are on display,
and yet somehow I always walk away from [inaudible] with a profound sense of
disappointment and that's because for all the [inaudible] talented developers,
all the hardware innovation,
all the technological advancements and all the new games,
you three can still feel remarkably uncreative year after year,
the gaming industry seems to fall back on one underlying theme
kill or be killed.
Wow.
After a few dozen trailers that all seem to feature essentially the same style
of gameplay.
The whole event can turn into a blur of flying bullets,
swinging swords and fiery explosions and that makes it hard not to feel a little
like Captain Picard on the holiday.
What are your here to do?
Asked for a refund.
Nah,
I made a killing freeze program
computer.
This isn't what I wanted at all.
Wants to violent.
I'm hit a relaxed,
not a dodge bullets.
Reconfigure
gaming is now a $100 billion a year industry and that's billion with a B and in
many ways he three represents the face that industry shows to the public.
As such,
the event provides an ideal setting to analyze overarching patterns in the
gaming moral.
So this year I did it quick statistical breakdown of all the games featured at
the major e three press conferences.
Let's see,
a total of 133 games were shown during these events.
That's only 20 of those games didn't include combat mechanics and 10 of those
were sports or racing games.
A detailed breakdown looks like this.
82% combat free percent minimal or incidental combat,
5% sports,
3% racing,
1% for dancing with just 7% leftover for all other combat games.
The fact that 82% of the games featured at e three our combat focused
illustrates a pretty serious lack of imagination
to see if that ratio holds up over time.
I went back and compared these stats to the numbers from previous e three events
and I found similar results.
Initially I had intended to include separate stats for a narrative games,
adventure games,
puzzle games,
city building games and exploration games,
but there just weren't enough titles in any of these genres to justify their own
category.
A couple quick notes about these numbers or these calculations.
I focused on combat rather than on the presence of violence,
so games in the non combat category aren't necessarily nonviolent.
In fact,
three of the 10 games in that category or rather violent survival horror
experiences.
I make the distinction between combat and violence because with combat the
player is the one doing the violence.
Violence is unfortunately part of our shared human history,
and so it makes sense that some games would include it.
However,
when combat is the games central focus,
it tends to celebrate that violence rather than framing it as a tragic last
resort.
One such perk,
we'll award the player with a tactical nukes following at 25 player kills
get red hot
dog.
Of course not all forms of combat are equal.
So just out of curiosity,
I further broke the stats down by type of the 108 games focusing on combat in
2017 20 of them.
It could be classified as cartoon violence are these titles,
it's less kill or be killed and more squish or be squashed.
The violence may be cute,
sometimes downright adorable,
but the focus on combat mechanics still sets up a hostile game environment in
which players are forced into an antagonistic relationship with the game.
World fee interactions may be a lot less bloody,
but the game play is still largely restricted to some form of get them before
they get you.
In many ways,
the gaming industry has backed itself into this corner.
For decades,
game studios have focused on combat to such a degree that for many gamers,
developers,
and even publishers,
combat has now become synonymous with gameplay itself.
The president of Nintendo of America echoed this sentiment at e three this year.
The game is fun.
The game is a battle.
If it's not fun,
why bother if it's not a battle,
where's the fun?
That's an extremely narrow definition of what constitutes a game and frankly I
didn't even narrower definition of fun.
I'd argued that this obsession with violent combat mechanics is holding the
gaming industry back.
Let me quickly explain why I say that.
Gameplay mechanics or the underlying rules and methods for engagement within a
game.
Think of mechanics as a set of tools that players are given with which to
interact with the game world,
its characters and other players.
In many of the Games we've been talking about,
combat is the only way to solve problems,
to resolve conflicts or to overcome obstacles.
That old saying that if all you have is a hammer,
everything looks like a nail is apropos
except video games are made so that nearly everything in your path is
specifically designed to actually be a nail.
And if you're given a machine gun as your primary tool for engagement,
that's going to determine how you approach the world.
And practically everything in it
is wanting to do is all
that I shot.
This other one showed a couple extra guys just to be shaved.
I did.
I did a lot of shooting about being totally honest.
When games focus so heavily on combat mechanics,
it's severely restricts the options for both emotional interaction and creative
conflict resolution or get back to it.
Don't get me wrong.
Conflict is of course an important part of storytelling,
but there are many forms of conflict from the interpersonal to the
intergalactic.
Likewise,
there are many forms of conflict resolution and most of them don't leave behind
a pile of bodies.
I should mention that there do exist a small handful of games that include
diplomatic tactics.
Layers can talk their way out of every situation in the retro Indie game.
Undertale but that's a rare exception to the rule.
Some genres like role playing games have players doing more than just fighting,
but most of the other forms of interaction exist to support the combat.
You talk to other characters.
We will give you quests West's which inevitably involve killing stuff.
You might buy,
sell or craft new items,
items that will help you in killing stuff
few days out in the wasteland and it's time to kick back at home.
My home,
you might even be able to build a house,
a house which you'll have to defend by killing even more stuff because you do
built defenses,
uh,
because your settlements can and will get attacked by Raiders.
All the other options available to players still ultimately revolve around that
core
combat.
Again,
this topic is of special concern to me because my work primarily focuses on the
representations of men and masculinity in entertainment.
Everywhere we look in pop culture,
we see models of manhood that are linked to confrontation,
aggression and violence.
And that's especially true in video games were male characters are rarely
depicted solving problems based on deescalation or compassion
to be affective in combat.
Award must not feel for his enemy.
Things like diplomacy,
deescalation,
negotiation and compromise.
I'll take a back seat to blunt force trauma
and that in turn dramatically limits the kinds of stories that can be told.
Now whenever I make these kinds of observations on social media,
someone will inevitably respond with a snarky quip about defeating monsters with
hugs or dancing or by serving tea and cupcakes.
They no doubt think these are devastating burns,
but actually those are pretty good ideas for innovative mechanics.
I play those games and I'm willing to bet that a whole hell of a lot of other
people would too.
Interactive media as an incredible,
almost unlimited potential to deliver a wide range of emotional deeply human
experiences that deal with love and connection and empathy.
Imagine an open world game where you take on the role of an EMT or a firefighter
or a field medic or a climate activist or an intergalactic veterinarian,
or how about a farmer who grows food on an intergenerational space ship?
We're imagine a game set in a post apocalyptic future because every other game I
saw at e three was set in a post apocalyptic future,
but instead of fighting over the scraps,
players cooperate to rebuild a better society.
Imagine all the stories we're missing out on because game developers insist on
building virtual worlds that we experience from behind the barrel of a gun or
the blade of a sword.
Yeah.
Remember that 7% of non combat focused games,
well,
every year e three does play host to a few small games that break the mold and
give us a glimpse into the medium is potential.
Tacoma is one such example.
You play as an investigator using augmented reality to solve a mystery of the
missing crew aboard a space station.
It's these small innovative titles that are blazing a path forward for
interactive storyteller.
We just need a whole lot more of them.
Okay.
If you'd like to see more of these long form video essays about the
intersections of manhood,
politics,
and entertainment,
then please go over to Patrion and help fund this project.
Every little bit helps me keep making more videos.
Next month's video will be about geeky sexism and the Big Bang theory.